* Laute Stimmen *
Jeder Mann hat das Gefühl,
dass er machen kann, was er will.
Viele Männer
sehen Frauen als Sexobjekt an.
* Laute Stimmen und Schreie *
Die Leute sind besoffen.
Das gibt unnötigen Stress.
* Pfiffe *
Die Gewalt
ist nicht schlimmer als früher.
Sie hat aber zugenommen,
auch gegen Frauen, ältere Leute
und beim Fussball gegen Kinder -
die Zielgruppe hat sich verändert.
Dass es tagtäglich passiert,
hat er gewusst.
Aber Josef Wartenweiler
hat niemals damit gerechnet,
dass es ihn treffen könnte.
Er ist auf dem Nachhauseweg,
als plötzlich zwei junge Männer
vor ihm stehen und zuschlagen.
Sie haben auf eine männliche Person,
die allein ist, gewartet.
Und per Zufall bin ich dann ...
Per Zufall
bin ich dort durchgegangen,
und da hat es mich erwischt.
Hinter dem Bahnhof in Winterthur
ist es passiert.
Die Jugendlichen verfolgen ihn,
halten ihn auf.
Er wird niedergeschlagen
und ausgeraubt.
Etwa hier auf dieser Höhe
ist es passiert.
Hatten Sie keine Chance?
Nein.
Als ich mich versuchte umzudrehen,
sah ich einen zweiten hinter mir.
Sie hatten das Überraschungsmoment.
Dann äh ... Ich habe versucht,
mich etwas zu wehren.
Aber zu wenig, oder ja ...
Die Täter erbeuten 43 Fr.
Diese Videoaufnahmen werden
den Haupttäter später überführen.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Videokameras filmen auch
Josef Wartenweiler nach dem Überfall.
Er sucht Hilfe bei einem
nahegelegenen Polizeiposten.
Doch um diese Zeit
ist der Posten nicht mehr besetzt.
Josef Wartenweiler steht unter Schock
und will wieder gehen.
Da kommt Hilfe.
Erst jetzt realisiert er,
wie schwer er verletzt ist:
Tiefe Messerstiche im Brustbereich,
unweit von Herz und Lunge.
Der zweite Täter
sagte bei der Einvernahme,
dass er mich noch
zu Boden schlagen wollte.
Er wollte erleben, wie es ist,
jemanden zu Boden zu schlagen.
Nach der Tat prahlt der Haupttäter
in einer WhatsApp-Nachricht
an Kollegen,
er habe gerade eben
einen niedergestochen.
(Mann) Hey Alter,
ich habe gerade einen abgestochen.
Er ist der Täter.
Er hat Josef Wartenweiler
überfallen - David.
Heute 22 Jahre alt, seit bald zwei
Jahren in der Strafanstalt Saxerriet.
Wir haben ihn damals
an der Gerichtsverhandlung getroffen.
David ist bereit,
mit uns über seine Tat zu sprechen.
Zur Tatzeit ist er 19 Jahre alt.
Er trinkt, nimmt Drogen
und holt sich notfalls mit Gewalt,
was er will.
Bei Herrn Wartenweiler
kam es mehr aus der Not,
weil ich nichts zu essen hatte - ich
war auf der Strasse, es war kalt.
Ich ass selten etwas.
Ich hatte wieder zu viel konsumiert.
Da dachte ich:
"Ich gehe in einen anderen Kanton,
halte jemanden ein Messer hin ..."
Zuerst wollte ich jemanden nieder-
schlagen und ihm das Geld wegnehmen.
Ich wollte aber
niemand Unschuldiges schlagen,
deshalb wollte ich ihn
mit einem Messer bedrohen,
damit er Angst hat
und mir das Geld gibt.
Es war nicht geplant,
dass er stolpert
und das Messer unabsichtlich
in die Brust eindringt.
Aber in einer WhatsApp-Nachricht
sagten Sie:
"Hey Alter,
ich habe einen niedergestochen."
Ja, das war eben
mein erster Eindruck.
Als ich dann daheim war,
überlegte ich:
"Er lief weg,
die Klinge war nicht schmutzig -
das kann gar nicht sein."
Ich war dann doch sehr erstaunt, als
ich vom Herrn Staatsanwalt erfuhr,
dass er mit einer einseitigen
Lungenembolie im Spital war.
Es hat die Lunge erwischt
und ging knapp am Herzen vorbei.
Da bin ich sehr erschrocken.
David ist ein Schweizer,
auch seine Eltern stammen von hier.
Da er zur Tatzeit volljährig ist,
trägt er die volle Verantwortung.
Vor Gericht begegnet er dem Opfer.
Das erste Mal seit dem Überfall.
Erst als ich das von Herrn
Wartenweiler eins zu eins hörte,
wurde mir wirklich bewusst,
wie das für ihn war.
Sicher habe ich mir vorher
viele Gedanken darüber gemacht,
wie das für das Opfer war.
Als ich es aber hörte und las,
war das für mich ganz anders.
Es gab mir mehr zu denken.
Das Urteil:
fünf Jahre und drei Monate Gefängnis.
Wie ist das, einen Menschen
zu schlagen und zu verletzen?
Was ist das für ein Gefühl?
Ich war noch nie Bungjee springen,
aber ich behaupte,
es ist ähnlich - ein Adrenalinkick.
Und kein Unrechtsbewusstsein?
- In diesem Moment nicht.
In diesem Moment überhaupt nicht.
Noch nie lebten wir in der Schweiz
so sicher wie heute.
Und doch:
Die Gewalt auf der Strasse nimmt zu.
Es ist Samstagabend.
Jan Wildhaber und Tosca Stucki
von der Basler Jugendpolizei
haben Nachtschicht.
Guten Abend.
Wir beginnen bei der Dreirosenanlage
und gehen Rhein-aufwärts
Richtung Wettsteinbrücke.
Schweizweit verzeichnet Basel die
höchste Dichte an Gewaltstraftaten.
Das urbane Basel.
Das Zentrum im Dreiländereck
Schweiz-Frankreich-Deutschland
zieht viele an.
In dieser Jahreszeit, wenn es schön
ist, ist das ein grosser Hotspot.
Das beginnt im Park der Dreirosen-
anlage, dort trifft man sich.
Und hier dem Rhein entlang
ist es natürlich schön,
wenn es warm ist,
beim Sonnenuntergang.
Noch ist es ruhig und der Abend jung.
Aber es ist Wochenende:
Da häufen sich die Schlägereien,
Messerstechereien und Überfälle.
Das Team der Jugendpolizei -
die beiden sind zivil unterwegs.
Ihr Ziel: Präsenz markieren, Kontakte
knüpfen, Beziehungen herstellen
und so Gewalt verhindern.
Am Theaterplatz, mitten in Basel.
Auf dem Platz treffen sich
junge Erwachsene und Jugendliche.
Die Stimmung ist noch friedlich.
Kommen Alkohol und Drogen ins Spiel,
kann sie jederzeit kippen.
# Higher powers taking a hold on me.
Kiffen, flexen, koksen ...
- Nein, was lügst du, Alter?
... schreddern, rauslassen.
Alles. Schauen Sie mal
die Leute an - 80 % Kanaken.
Kurden, Albaner -
Schlägerei heisst Polizei.
Irgendwann ist fertig lustig.
Es passiert alles Mögliche.
Man muss für alles bereit sein.
Drei- bis viermal in der Nacht
kommen die beiden hier vorbei.
Je öfter sie vor Ort sind, desto eher
lässt sich die Gewalt verhindern.
Wir fühlen nun einfach den Puls,
wir schauen, wie die Stimmung
unter den Jungen ist.
Wir schauen, ob alles gut ist.
Gut? Aha, seid ihr von der Polizei?
Es kann sein, dass schon um 22 Uhr
hier etwas los ist.
Oder es kann generell in der Stadt
eine Schlägerei geben.
Wir hörten über Funk
von einer Schlägerei,
das war zwischen 21 und 21.30 Uhr.
Das kann man nie genau voraussagen.
Aber tendenziell ist es schon so:
Je später der Abend wird, desto mehr
beginnen die Schlägereien.
Eine Lehrstelle hast du?
- Ja.
Super, perfekt. Hauptsache, du
hast eine Lehrstelle gefunden.
Und du?
Verlässliche Beziehungen
zu Erwachsenen, das weiss man heute,
vermindern die Gewaltbereitschaft.
Und Beziehung bedeutet auch,
Grenzen und Regeln zu akzeptieren.
Polizisten sind normale Menschen.
Normale Menschen, wie jemand,
der bei der Bank oder Post arbeitet.
Auf Deutsch gesagt: Wenn sie
keinen Respekt uns gegenüber zeigen,
warum sollen wir sie
dann respektieren?
Wenn man mich respektiert,
respektiere ich jeden.
So bin ich zu jedem Menschen -
es ist einfach so.
Aber letzthin hatte ein Polizist
keinen Respekt vor mir,
dann war ich auch so.
- Was heisst das?
Ich war nicht sehr nett zu ihm.
Wir hatten hier
auch schon verletzte Polizisten.
Das Problem
sind die vielen Glasflaschen.
Liegen viele leere Alkoholflaschen
rum, weiss man,
wie viel Alkohol die Leute
schon konsumiert haben.
Auch die Art und Weise
wie sie teils schon rumlaufen,
wie sie sich präsentieren
und zeigen, dass sie da sind ...
Man sieht auch gewisse Gruppen,
die herausstechen.
Es kann schnell passieren,
dass die Stimmung plötzlich kippt.
Tosca Stucki und Jan Wildhaber
werden zu einem Einsatz
der Kantonspolizei gerufen.
Rivalisierende Jugendgruppen sollen
hier aufeinander losgegangen sein.
Was ist passiert? Eine Schlägerei?
Nein, mein Kollege und ich
haben wegen einer Frau gestritten.
Wegen einer Frau? Wegen dir?
- Ja genau.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen.
Es ist also schon erledigt.
- Alles erledigt.
Sicher?
- Es ist nichts Schlimmes passiert.
Es geht um Macht und Ehre -
und um Frauen.
V.a. für Jugendliche ist das offenbar
oft Auslöser für Schlägereien.
Es ist die gleiche Klientel,
wie wir vorher
auf dem Theaterplatz hatten.
Es sind Jugendliche
und junge Erwachsene.
Ähm ...
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund.
Hier war das Problem,
dass es um eine Frau ging.
Es geht um eine junge Frau,
um die sie sich gestritten haben.
Eine andere Gruppe war hier,
die anscheinend die Freundin
von einem angemacht haben.
Dann kam es, laut ihren Aussagen,
zur verbalen Auseinandersetzung.
Laut den Aussagen der
Requirierenden, die angerufen hat,
kam es anscheinend
zu einem Handgemenge.
Sag den Kollegen,
dass alle wieder friedlich sind,
dass die Sache erledigt ist.
Ist das gut so? - Ja.
Schönen Tag. Tschüss!
- Mach's gut! Pass gut auf!
Viele Leute denken, dass v.a.
Jugendliche oder junge Erwachsene
mit Migrationshintergrund
schwierig sind. Ist das so?
In dieser Situation war es so.
Aber ob das
im Allgemeinen so ist ...
Es gibt auch jugendliche Schweizer,
die aggressiv sein können.
Hier waren es eben junge Erwachsene
mit einem Migrationshintergrund.
Die Gewalt auf der Strasse
ist ein gesellschaftliches Phänomen
und betrifft Schweizer und Ausländer
gleichermassen.
* Instrumentale Rap-Musik *
Warum schlägt ein junger Mensch
zu? Geht es um Macht? Um Stärke?
(Rap) # Ich stelle mich gegen jeden,
darum sitze ich das hier ab.
# Ich scheisse auf Hashtags,
pervers, ich chatte etwas Blutiges.
Vor Ajrim
hatten die anderen früher Angst.
Heute ist er ein Rapper
und übt für sein nächstes Konzert.
Die Musik, die Texte sind aggressiv.
Aber genau damit kriegt
er seine Wut heute in den Griff.
(Rap) # Entscheidet euch richtig.
Bleibt euren Seelen treu!
Jetzt habe ich den Schluss verkackt.
Aber das ist ja nur eine Übung.
Heute denke ich:
"Wie konnte ich nur so drauf sein?"
"Woher kam diese Wut?"
Das frage ich mich manchmal auch.
Sie war ...
Sie war in einem riesigen Ausmass
vorhanden.
Ich verstehe das selber nicht.
Als ich früher zurückblickte,
dachte ich,
dass doch nicht so schlimm war.
Aber jetzt sehe ich,
was ich alles gemacht habe ...
Dieses Bündel Akten dokumentiert
einen kleinen Teil
seiner bewegten Vergangenheit.
Hier habe ich ein Urteil
über acht Sachbeschädigungen,
"Fahren ohne Führerausweis, Wider-
handlung gegen das Waffengesetz."
"Pflichtwidriges Verhalten
bei einem Unfall."
"Widerhandlung
gegen das Betäubungsmittelgesetz."
Und das war  e i n  Urteil.
* Einzelne Klaviertöne *
Wir fahren mit Ajrim dahin zurück,
wo er aufgewachsen ist.
Mit 14
hat er das erste Mal zugeschlagen.
Ein falscher Blick
reichte damals manchmal schon.
Es gibt ein Anschauen und Wegschauen
und es gibt eben ein Anschauen
und Provozieren,
und wenn man
mit der Freundin ist ...
Heute ist das nicht mehr so.
Aber damals ...
Vielleicht,
weil ich auch nur das hatte.
D.h., ich hatte keinen Status
in der Gesellschaft.
Ich hatte nicht einmal
einen Schulabschluss, keine Lehre.
Das Einzige, was ich hatte,
war mein Stolz.
Heute würde ich sagen,
es war ein falscher Stolz.
Aber damals dachte ich,
ich sei unantastbar.
Kleiner Motherfucker!
Dennis
ist einer seiner Jugendfreunde.
Heute machen die beiden
zusammen Musik.
Aufgewachsen ist Ajrim
im St. Galler Rheintal,
in Altstätten.
Seine Mutter, eine Schweizerin,
ist alleinerziehend.
Den Vater kennt er nicht.
Von ihm hat er einzig
seinen albanischen Vornamen.
Ajrim und Dennis:
beide haben zu Hause Gewalt erlebt.
Dennis vom Vater, bei Ajrim
war es später der Stiefvater.
Was hat man in Altstätten
von Ajrim gedacht?
Am besten hatte man nichts mit ihm
zu tun, weil es sonst Stress gab.
So war es.
Man hat auch Abstand gehalten,
weil man sich nicht kannte.
"Ich habe keine Probleme mit dir,
und ich hoffe,
du hast keine mit mir."
So gingen wir unsere Wege.
Hat dir das Macht gegeben, Ajrim?
Damals vielleicht schon,
aber heute fühlt es sich blöd an,
wenn ich durch Altstätten gehe.
Damals dachte ich:
"Wenn ich hier durchlaufe,
schauen sie mich
nicht mehr schräg an."
"Sie schauen auf den Boden."
Das ist falscher Respekt,
das ist Angst.
Niemand wollte
etwas mit mir zu tun haben.
Sie hatten nur mit mir zu tun,
weil sie Angst hatten.
Ich habe daraus gelernt,
dass sie Angst hatten.
Ich spüre die Blicke, aber heute
fühle ich keine Macht mehr.
Heute ist es eher Scham.
Ajrim ist der Ältere,
er war zwei Klassen über Dennis.
Das ist im ersten Stockwerk,
nicht wahr?
Dieses Scheissschulhaus, Alter.
Ich war oft auf dem Dach.
- Sicher? Ich kein einziges Mal.
Ich habe auf dem Dach einen Joint
geraucht und ging dann wieder rein.
* Dennis lacht. *
Ich habe zwei Lehrer
zum Burn-out getrieben.
Beim dritten
bin ich kurz vorher geflogen.
Wenn man zu Hause verprügelt wird,
hat das einen Einfluss darauf,
dass man selber prügelt?
Ja, sicher auch.
Ähm ...
Man hat innerlich
sicher Aggressionen.
Das hat aber nichts mit den Menschen
zu tun, denen man begegnet.
Zu Hause kann man es aber
nicht rauslassen,
weil es dein Vater ist
und du ihm Respekt zollen musst.
Man ist sicher leichter gereizt.
Der Schulhausplatz
im st. gallischen Altstätten,
ein beliebter Treffpunkt
für die Jungen.
Das war auch bei Ajrim und Dennis so.
Wie alt seid ihr,
wenn ich fragen darf? - 25.
Auch einmal hier in die Schule
gegangen, viel Scheisse gemacht,
aber gebracht hat es nichts.
Man ist nicht geiler,
wenn man prahlen kann,
dass man den und den verprügelt hat.
Das bringt einem nichts -
nur Probleme.
Als du geprügelt hast, bist du
mit Messern dorthin gegangen?
Ich hatte immer eines dabei,
aber ich habe einen
mit einem Stein geschlagen.
Aber das lohnt sich nicht.
Ich war zum eigenen Schutz be-
waffnet. Aber das braucht es nicht.
Lass dich nicht darauf ein,
verpiss dich!
Du willst doch keinen umbringen
oder selber sterben.
Wenn dir einer Hurensohn sagt,
dann steh darüber.
Deine Mutter
freut sich nicht darüber,
dass du einen verprügelt hast,
nur weil sie beleidigt wurde. - Ja.
Habt ihr schon Messer?
- Nein.
Weshalb lügst du?
Also kein Messer?
- Nein, ich habe kein Messer dabei.
Und Hurensohn
sagt ihr euch gegenseitig?
Ja, zum Spass.
Wir verwenden das Wort Hurensohn
oft gegenüber Kollegen.
Aber wir nehmen es
einfach nicht ernst.
Und warum gibt es Prügeleien?
Wegen Hurensohn
prügeln wir uns nicht.
Aber wenn es darauf ankommt,
wenn einer z.B. gewalttätig wird.
Bei mir ist es so:
Wenn mich jemand schlägt,
dann schlage ich gleich zurück.
Ja, so ist es bei mir.
Ajrim, das hört sich
wie bei Ihnen an?
In diesem Alter
hätte ich dasselbe gesagt.
Es gibt viele, die sofort schlagen,
die Schlägertypen sind.
Warum denn?
Die fackeln nicht lange.
Sie schlagen gleich drein.
Machen die Mädchen das auch?
- Eher nicht.
Wir diskutieren lieber.
Wir zicken vielleicht rum
oder streiten,
aber die Buben schlagen einfach zu.
Ich weiss nicht,
warum die Buben das machen.
Ajrim und Dennis leben schon länger
nicht mehr
im st. gallischen Altstätten,
aber man kennt sie immer noch.
Heute gelten sie als cool
und ihre Musik erst recht.
* Rap *
Krass!
Hier im Rheintal
hatten wir einfach nichts.
Hier gab es einen Jugendtreff,
für den wir alle früher oder später
ein Verbot bekommen haben.
Dann gingen wir eben raus
und kifften.
Wir haben uns mit anderen
von anderen Dörfern geprügelt,
weil wir nicht wussten,
was wir machen sollten.
Zürich. Mitten in der Partyszene.
* Rap *
Ich habe kürzlich gesehen,
wie eine vorbeiging
und einen Klaps auf den Arsch bekam.
Da wurde sogar ich fast wütend.
Man muss die Frauen respektieren.
Auch wenn man ...
- Haben Sie etwas gesagt?
Nein, dann stehe ich schlecht da.
Man kann nichts machen.
Es kommt immer darauf an,
wie die Frau gekleidet ist.
Wenn sie einen Minirock
bis hier oben trägt,
muss sie sich nicht wundern,
wenn sie betatscht wird.
Aber ...
* Alle lachen *
Und ja ...
- Ist sie also selbst schuld?
Schauen Sie,
wenn Sie eine Tochter hätten,
die mit solchen High Heels,
einem solchen Minirock
und einem solchen Ausschnitt
in den Ausgang gehen würde ...
Die Männer würden sie doch anschauen
oder vielleicht begrapschen?
Frauen als Freiwild?
Weil sie sich so anziehen und weil
sie so sind, wie es ihnen gefällt?
(Frau, schreiend) Nein, Mann,
das darfst du mir nicht sagen.
Begrapscht und bedrängt werden -
das ist für viele junge Frauen
heute fast normal.
Ich denke, das hat jede
schon einmal erlebt.
Aber es kommt mega darauf an,
wie man handelt.
Man darf es nicht
einfach ignorieren.
Sobald man nichts macht,
denke ich, dass man ...
Nicht das Einverständnis gibt, aber
es ist einfach keine Grenze mehr da.
Ich habe das auch schon erlebt.
Es ist sehr unangenehm.
Hier kommen so viele Kulturen
und so viele verschiedene
Altersklassen zusammen.
Ich bin 18, 19. Es gibt Leute hier,
die viel jünger sind.
Und die kommen hinein.
Und dann gibt es Männer,
die, ohne Witz, 60 sind
und es gibt Männer, die 34 sind.
Hier prallt alles aufeinander.
Es gibt keine Grenzen,
für niemanden.
V.a. wenn niemand reklamiert.
- Das ist so.
Die neusten Zahlen belegen:
Sexuelle Belästigung trifft mehr
als die Hälfte der jungen Frauen.
Remo Schmid ist in Zürich auf-
gewachsen und kennt die Partyszene.
Er hat in Clubs gearbeitet,
Konzerte veranstaltet.
Er hat oft beobachtet,
wie Frauen behandelt werden.
Das Problem, sagt er,
seien der Alkohol, die Drogen und -
die Männer.
Was denken die heutigen Männer
von den Frauen?
Dass man sie schnell ...
* Laute Stimmen *
... sie schnell ... äh ...
... schnell haben kann.
Cockies?
Ein Beispiel:
Geht eine Frau an einem vorbei ...
Man geht mit den Fingern auf die
Frau zu, versucht sie anzufassen.
Klar hat man dann
als Frau etwas Angst.
Das haben wir hier eben gesehen.
Sie machte einen Bogen um ihn herum
und er ist alleine unterwegs.
Ich weiss nicht, wieso die Männer
das z.T. so machen.
Das kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Remo Schmid hat letztes Jahr
den Prix Courage gewonnen,
weil er mutig eingeschritten ist,
als er gesehen hat,
wie eine Frau geschlagen
und sexuell bedrängt wurde.
Ich kenne viele Frauen, die sich auf
den Strassen nicht mehr wohlfühlen.
Sie fühlen sich nicht mehr wohl,
nachts alleine nach Hause zu gehen.
Man muss immer Angst haben,
man werde angepöbelt.
Man muss als Frau damit leben.
So wie auch als Mann, der von einer
Gruppe attackiert werden kann.
Das sind Sachen,
die heutzutage ganz normal sind.
Die kann man nicht mehr wegdenken.
Das ist neu, dass auch Frauen
auf der Strasse verprügelt werden.
Einfach so
und mit der gleichen Härte.
Genau das
ist der 27-jährigen Anna passiert.
Ich weiss nicht, in diesem Moment
habe ich mich gefragt,
ob ich etwas Falsches
oder etwas Freches gesagt habe.
War ich falsch angezogen?
Alles solche Sachen.
War das so?
- Nein.
Nein, auch nicht frech - nichts.
Seither
ist sie nie mehr am Tatort gewesen.
Wir gehen mit ihr dorthin zurück,
an die Hauptstrasse in Dübendorf,
wo es passiert ist.
Es ist Nacht, es fahren Autos vorbei,
das Quartier ist dicht bewohnt.
Ihr Glück,
dass auch Remo Schmid hier wohnt.
Er hörte ihre Schreie und beschloss,
nachzuschauen, was da los war.
Du warst ja ...
Ja, ich bin nach hinten
über den Zaun gerannt.
Dann sind wir wieder
nach hinten gegangen.
Und du hast ihn erwischt?
- Ja, da hinten.
Der Täter, betrunken und
unter Drogen, schlägt brutal zu.
Ich habe gespürt,
dass er hinter mir her war.
Dann habe ich den Notfall angerufen.
Ich konnte noch sagen, wo ich war.
Ich lief da hinüber, setzte mich
auf die Bank und da hat er mich ...
Es war cool, dass du dich hinter
der Scheibe schützen konntest.
Er konnte mich
nur auf eine Seite schlagen.
Die andere Seite war ...
Einmal hat er mir den Kopf ...
Einmal schlug er mir
den Kopf dort hinein.
Er hat mich ständig geschlagen.
Remo Schmid eilte zu Hilfe
und verhinderte,
dass Anna nicht auch noch
sexuell missbraucht wurde.
Wie hat der Täter reagiert?
Anfangs war er kollegial.
Er meinte, ich solle weitergehen,
das sei seine Freundin.
Als ich sah, dass es ihr
nicht gut ging, war mir klar:
Auch wenn es seine Freundin ist,
muss ich hier bleiben
und die Situation klären oder
schauen, dass sie in Sicherheit ist.
Nachdem er gemerkt hat,
dass ich nicht wegging,
wurde er sehr aggressiv.
Er bedrohte mich.
Er drohte auch, auf mich loszugehen.
Und das tat er dann auch.
Die Erinnerung wühlt auf.
Mir ist es schwindlig.
Willst du etwas trinken?
Nein.
- Hat es hier keinen Brunnen?
Ich habe so viele Schläge
eingesteckt. Ich war ...
Ich konnte gar nichts mehr sagen
und machen. Mir tat alles weh.
Sprechen ...
Ich war sehr erleichtert,
als jemand eingriff.
Wenn ich die Häuser hier neben
der Haltestelle sehe, denke ich,
dass man schneller
hätte reagieren ihr helfen können.
Aber es ist eben wieder ...
eben wieder, dass ... äh ...
... dass Menschen sich heutzutage
nicht mehr gegenseitig helfen.
Seit das passiert ist,
habe ich mir fest vorgenommen,
dass ich mich für Menschen einsetze,
die Hilfe brauchen
und keine bekommen.
So wird sich das bei uns in Zukunft
vielleicht ein wenig verändern,
dass mehr Menschen
sich gegenseitig helfen.
Das hoffe ich und dafür kämpfe ich.
Den 30-jährigen Täter
sieht Anna vor Gericht wieder:
Er wird zu einer bedingten
Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
und muss
eine ambulante Therapie machen.
Was war das für ein Typ?
Als ich ihn nachher
bei Gericht sah ...
Ganz normal, Schweizer ...
Eigentlich wirkte er ganz normal.
Er ist ein Typ, dem man nie zutrauen
würde, dass er so etwas macht.
Gross, ja gross war er.
Jawohl.
Anna belastet der Übergriff
bis heute.
Immer noch sucht sie
nach einer Erklärung.
Haben Sie mit dem Täter gesprochen?
Ja, vor der Anwältin.
Ich habe ihm immer
eine Frage gestellt,
die er nicht beantworten konnte.
Was haben Sie ihn gefragt?
- Warum er das gemacht hat.
Ich habe die Schuld
lange bei mir gesucht.
Nachher sagte man mir,
ich hätte keine Schuld.
Dann wollte ich ihn fragen: Warum?
Eine Antwort hat sie nie bekommen.
Remo Schmid hat geholfen.
Hätten andere das auch gemacht
oder wäre die Angst dabei grösser,
sich selber in Gefahr zu bringen?
Es ist leider sehr oft so,
dass Menschen, die helfen,
selber zum Opfer werden.
Man sollte den Menschen aufzeigen,
wie sie helfen können,
ohne dass sie selber
in diese Maschinerie kommen
und ein negatives Erlebnis haben.
Das ist das Ziel der Kampagne.
Die Zürcher Stadtpolizei
wirbt für mehr Zivilcourage
mit einer mobilen Beratungsstelle.
Hier werden mögliche
Alltagssituationen nachgestellt.
Z.B. im Tram.
Jemand wird bedrängt.
Wie reagieren?
Interaktiv kann man
auf die Situation einwirken
und schauen,
wie man sich richtig verhält.
Solche Sachen nützen enorm.
Das ist eine Situation, die ich
täglich in Zügen und im Tram sehe.
Man sitzt spätabends alleine und
eine Gruppe Männer kommt herein.
Man fühlt sich dann unwohl und weiss
nicht, wie man reagieren soll.
Wenn man das mehr zeigt und
den jungen Leuten bewusster macht,
ist das enorm.
Es hat auch mich sehr überrascht,
dass man daraus lernen kann.
Beim zweiten Mal
hätte ich es anders gemacht.
Richtig handeln heisst:
hinschauen, helfen.
Aber zum eigenen Schutz
zuerst andere mobilisieren
und die Polizei-Notrufnummer 117
wählen.
Bevor man einschreitet,
sollte man die Polizei anrufen,
ihr sagen, wo man ist,
was man feststellt,
und dass man dazwischen gehen wird.
Zivilcourage kann man lernen.
Und Gewalt verhindern, fängt mit
einer aufmerksamen Gesellschaft an.
In Basel
ist es inzwischen 3 Uhr in der Früh
und die Jugendpolizei
ist voll im Einsatz.
Das ist aber ein grosses Aufgebot.
Ja. Meinst du hier?
- Ja.
Es ist eigentlich
ein kleines Aufgebot.
Ein kleines?
- Ja, ja.
Es sind nicht so viele hier.
Sonst hat es viel mehr, aber es ist
keine sehr grosse Gruppe,
die man kontrollieren muss.
* Alle sprechen durcheinander. *
Und wieder geht es
um Ehre, Macht und Frauen.
Der eine Typ war sehr komisch.
Er versuchte, sie anzumachen und so.
Er sagte ihr,
ich sei ein Hurensohn.
Dann habe ich ihn angerufen.
Ich fragte ihn,
wieso er mich Hurensohn nennt.
Ich war ein guter Freund von ihm.
"Du sagst Hurensohn.
Was hat meine Mutter damit zu tun?"
Dann ist er ausgerastet und sagte,
ich sei ein Hurensohn.
Dann haben wir uns
gegenseitig beleidigt.
Die Polizei setzt klare Grenzen.
Ungewohnt
für viele der Jugendlichen.
Jetzt gehst du nach Hause!
Okay, haben wir uns verstanden?
Geh jetzt nach Hause!
Meine Kollegen ...
- Du wartest auf dieser Seite!
Sonst pennst du bei uns.
Ist das klar?
Ein grosser Teil ist sicher
auch Prävention - präventiv.
Aber auch repressiv.
Es braucht beides.
Man muss den Kontakt mit ihnen
suchen, präsent sein.
Man muss sie aufsuchen.
Man muss ihnen auch ganz klar
die Grenzen setzen.
Ist das einfach so?
Gehört das zu unserer Gesellschaft?
Ich habe schon das Gefühl,
dass das dazugehört.
Dass sich der Blickwinkel
der Jugendlichen
oder der Gesellschaft verändert hat.
Ja, dass man als Frau oder Mädchen
im Ausgang angegrapscht
oder betatscht wird.
Oder wie wir vorher hörten, dass man
einander Kraftausdrücke austeilt.
Das ist heutzutage
unter den Jugendlichen ganz normal.
Leider hat sich der Blickwinkel
recht verändert.
Auch Ajrim
ist um diese Zeit noch unterwegs.
Seit ein paar Jahren lebt er in Basel
und schaut kritisch auf das,
was sich tagtäglich
auf der Strasse abspielt.
Es sei heute dasselbe wie damals,
sagt er. Nur härter.
In diesem Viertel ist es
am Wochenende gang und gäbe.
Es gehört zum Standard.
Man kann schon fast sagen
wie im Zoo.
Man weiss, dass es hier
zu gewissen Zeiten Randale gibt.
Neu ist: die Schlägereien
werden gefilmt und ins Netz gestellt.
Als ob die Bilder Trophäen wären.
Messen zwischen Nationalitäten,
messen zwischen Geld,
wer hat mehr Geld.
Messen, wer der Krassere ist.
Alles wird gemessen.
Wer hat mehr wovon.
Wenn einer weniger hat,
schlägt er zu.
Wenn einer mehr hat, meint er,
er könne auf dem anderen treten.
Wer eine Schlägerei sucht,
der findet sie.
Ajrim führt uns wieder
auf den Theaterplatz.
Die Polizei ist nicht mehr vor Ort
und unsere Kamera unauffällig.
Es geht nicht lange
und schon sind wir live dabei.
Dort hinter mir
gibt es eine Schlägerei.
* Laute Stimmen *
* Schreie und laute Stimmen *
Ich war eigentlich
auf dem Nachhauseweg.
Er hat mich geschupst
und ich bin aufgestanden.
Dann habe ich zugeschlagen,
weil er mich auch geschlagen hat.
Ich bin Boxer.
Ich lasse mich nicht auf Stress ein,
muss mich aber verteidigen.
Ich habe sie getrennt.
Einer bekam ein, zwei Schläge
und lag am Boden.
Ich habe sie getrennt. Einer
kam mit dem Gürtel auf mich zu.
Ich war schon in Kampfposition,
aber nur, um mich zu schützen.
Warum passiert das überhaupt?
Wie bitte?
- Warum passiert das überhaupt?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Die heutige Gewalt
ist viel intensiver.
Früher hat es auch geknallt,
aber anders.
Heute ist die Gewalt enorm intensiv.
Man greift auch schneller
zu Gegenständen.
Man verabredet sich schneller
oder man ruft sich an.
So wie vorher,
als wir zu der Gruppe kamen.
Wir haben mitbekommen,
dass einer Probleme hatte
und seine Kollegen angerufen hat.
Es seien dann anscheinend
rund 30 Kollegen kommen.
Es ist sicher brutaler,
man greift schneller zu Gegenständen
und es knallt auch schneller.
Der Platanenhof.
Ajrim war 15 Jahre alt,
als er hierherkam.
Er musste drei Jahre bleiben.
Der Platanenhof
galt lange schweizweit
als eines der härtesten Jugendheime.
Ein Heim für solche,
wie Ajrim einer war.
* Klopfen *
Hallo, ich bin wieder zurück.
- Oh, hoi!
Grüezi, Grüeziwohl!
- Hoi!
Geht es gut?
- Wie geht es dir?
Geht es dir gut?
- Ja. Dir auch?
Schön, dich zu sehen.
- Schön, wieder einmal hier zu sein.
Es hat sich ein wenig verändert.
Hast du die Gruppe
so gross in Erinnerung?
Nein,
wir hatten keinen Billardtisch.
War er nicht im Keller? - Nein,
wir hatten nur einen Fussballtisch.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass wir noch einmal telefonieren,
wenn ich draussen bin.
Z.T. bin ich ja mit dem Messer
auf euch losgegangen.
Wir hatten
ganz schlimme Streitereien.
Weil wir Streit hatten,
hatten wir eine Beziehung.
Genau, aber da flogen Worte
und Sachen durch den Raum ...
Ich hätte das nie gedacht.
Alles kann sich ändern.
Das ist brutal.
Mit dir habe ich
am meisten gestritten. - Ja.
Tagtäglich. Das war ja ...
- Ja, von morgens bis abends.
Bis ihr mich
nur aus dem Bett gebracht habt!
Meistens habe ich mich verweigert.
Jeden zweiten Morgen
wurde mir angedroht,
48 Std. in eine Einzelzelle
zu kommen.
Das gehörte damals
und auch heute noch zum Konzept:
Wer renitent ist
und sich nicht an Regeln hält,
wird in eine Einzelzelle gesperrt.
Ajrim war oft hier.
Hier?
- Ja.
Es ist krass.
Ich hatte es nicht mehr so
in Erinnerung, aber es ist brutal.
In den 48 Std. damit umgehen ...
Da dreht sich in einem alles.
Nach 8 Std. alleine ist man so lange
drin, dass man wieder wütend wird.
Nach 40 Std. wünscht du dir
nur noch, hinauszukommen.
Es ist ein sehr gemischtes Gefühl.
Es war echt schwierig.
Wenn du dich hier drinnen
nicht bewegen kannst
und wie ein Tiger im Käfig
im Kreis gehst,
dann staut sich die Energie.
Wenn man nachher kein Ventil hat, um
sie rauszulassen, dreht man durch.
Was hätten Sie gebraucht, damit Sie
nicht so gewalttätig geworden wären?
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich glaube, mein ganzes Leben
hätte anders verlaufen müssen.
Die Wut in mir
kam von gewissen Ereignissen in
meiner Kindheit und in der Jugend.
Es hätte etwas passieren müssen,
das mich von dieser Gewalt
weggebracht hätte.
Aber damit es sie
nie gegeben hätte,
hätte mein ganzes Leben
anders verlaufen müssen.
In Einzelhaft hat er
seine ersten Rap-Texte geschrieben
und ein Ventil
für seine Aggressionen gefunden.
Können Sie mir erklären,
woher seine Aggression kommt?
Also Ajrim
müsste seine Geschichte aufrollen,
seine Geschichte der Familie,
vom ganzen Umfeld,
die ganze Situation:
die Mutter und seine Überforderung.
Da sind sicher die ... äh ...
Wie sagt man?
Das war sicher der Start des Ganzen.
Ich finde, du warst schon
ein bisschen dir selbst überlassen.
Ja.
- In gewissen Situationen.
Ziemlich.
- Im Leben.
Gut, aufgewachsen ohne Vater
oder mit einem anderen Vater,
einem Stiefvater. Also ...
Mit ihm gab es eben auch Probleme.
Die festen Beziehungen
haben ihm gefehlt.
Die Mutter
war in dieser Situation alleine.
Ist das die Ursache für viele Jungen?
Keine Beziehung oder zu wenig.
Wenn ich jetzt einige ...
Ich will jetzt nicht einfach
die Mütter verurteilen und sagen:
Alle alleinstehenden Mütter
schaffen es nicht.
Aber tatsächlich
sind die zerrütteten Familien ...
Die zerrütteten Familien sind schon
sehr schlimm für die Jugendlichen.
Der Verlust des Vaters,
also er ist nicht anwesend ...
Das ganze Umfeld. Umso mehr
die soziale Kontrolle da ist,
umso mehr fühlen sie sich behütet.
Das ist wie ein Nest.
Wenn das Nest
sozusagen zerstört ist,
dann fühlt man sich da
alleingelassen.
Ajrim hat hier
auch seine Ausbildung nachgeholt.
Hallo, Lisa!
- Hallo!
Schön, dass ich kommen darf.
Grüezi, Herr Gisler.
Wieder einmal hier.
Was machst du gegenwärtig?
Ich bin in der Gewerbeschule
in Basel, immer noch als Koch.
Ich habe einiges von Ihnen gelernt.
Sie sind auch immer noch ...
Es freut mich, dass du
im Metier geblieben bist.
Hut ab! - Dankeschön.
Ja, die ganzen sieben Jahre.
Ajrim hat hier bekommen,
was er dringend brauchte:
Strukturen und letztlich auch
Menschen, die an ihn geglaubt haben.
Ich habe jetzt wirklich Skrupel
davor, jemanden zu schlagen.
Ich möchte niemanden verletzen.
Ich mache auch Battle-Rap,
und das ist mein Ventil:
Ich kann 1 Std. vor dem Mikrofon
stehen und schreien.
Dort lasse ich meine Wut heraus.
Danach bin ich recht beruhigt.
Dann kann ich mich auf der Strasse
auch provozieren lassen.
Da ich meinen Druck
schon abgelassen habe,
macht mir das nichts mehr aus.
Aber ich brauchte schon ein Ventil,
denn die Energie ist immer noch da.
Ich versuche es jetzt in eine
positive Energie umzuwandeln.
Darum muss ich
nicht mehr zuschlagen.
Ich habe auch den Hass nicht mehr.
Ich habe zwar die Energie
und die Rebellion,
aber es ist nicht mehr böse.
David, der 22-jährige junge Mann,
der einen Passanten
brutal mit dem Messer
angegriffen und ausgebraubt hat,
sitzt noch bis November 2023
im Gefängnis.
Im Erwachsenenvollzug ist er hart
auf dem Boden der Realität gelandet.
Mit 18 ging es noch ein Jahr und
dann kam gleich die erste Strafe.
Das hat mich
auch ein wenig überrumpelt.
Anfangs habe ich es
gar nicht so schlimm wahrgenommen.
Das kam erst mit der Zeit,
als ich hier angekommen,
etwas ruhiger geworden bin und mich
der Situation angepasst habe.
Dann kam das nach und nach.
Ich würde behaupten,
dass ich erst nach einem halben Jahr
darüber nachgedacht habe,
welches Ausmass meine Taten hatten.
Was ich gemacht habe,
wusste ich immer.
Aber welches Ausmass das
für alle Beteiligten hatte,
war mir nicht bewusst.
Vielleicht wollte ich auch nicht,
dass es mir bewusst wurde.
Ich habe es absichtlich verdrängt.
Nicht gemerkt,
dass Sie nun erwachsen sind?
Ich habe quasi
den Übertritt nicht mitbekommen.
Ich hatte auch niemanden,
der mich darauf vorbereitet hat,
weil ich mit 17 alleine dastand.
Ich musste immer
alles selber machen.
Ich hatte niemanden, der mir
das Erwachsenwerden beibrachte.
David arbeitet im Gefängnis
in der Metallverarbeitung.
Wenn er sich gut verhält,
kann er vielleicht
die Gefängniszeit nutzen
und eine Ausbildung machen.
Ohne aus dem Täter
ein Opfer machen zu wollen -
die Frage bleibt dennoch:
Was muss in einer Biographie
alles schieflaufen,
dass so eine Entwicklung
möglich ist?
Was würden Sie einem Jugendlichen
sagen, der so wie Sie ist?
Die Finger von Drogen lassen.
Oder sich vorher genug Hilfe suchen.
Weil es alles andere als cool ist.
Konnte Sie etwas stoppen?
- Nein, ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich habe immer
extra das Gegenteil gemacht.
Aber ich hoffe,
dass nicht alle so sind wie ich.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Würden Sie es ändern,
wenn Sie könnten?
Ich würde gerne
zurück zu meiner Kindheit.
Ich würde alles
komplett anders machen.
In die Kanti gehen, studieren,
etwas arbeiten.
Das können Sie jetzt auch hoch.
Ja, aber jetzt ist es
dreimal so schwer.
Ich habe viel Zeit verschenkt.
Das schmerzt am meisten.
Und das Opfer? Viele bleiben nach
so einem Übergriff traumatisiert.
Josef Wartenweiler sagt,
er habe die Tat verarbeitet.
Ist es eine Genugtuung für ihn,
zu wissen,
dass der Täter bestraft wurde?
Das Strafmass
ist mir eigentlich egal.
Ich bin froh, dass er gefasst wurde.
Er wurde verurteil
und bekommt seine Strafe.
Weil ich aber
keine Erwartungen hatte,
ist es mehr ...
Jetzt ist es erledigt.
Ich war froh, als alles vorbei war
und ich es abschliessen konnte.
Jetzt ist es definitiv.
Das wurde mir bewusst,
als ich am Tag der
Gerichtsverhandlung nach Hause fuhr.
Ich war erleichtert,
weil es nun zu Ende ist.
* Rapp *
Und Ajrim?
Er steht am Anfang
seiner Rapper-Karriere.
Schön, dass ihr mich
aufgenommen habt
und ich heute hier auftreten kann.
Danke, Bruder.
- Schön.